a vaccine hack from north korea the
rogue nation
reportedly trying to break into
astrazeneca's major breakthrough
on a covet 19 vaccine fox's david spunt
has the latest
from the department of justice kind of
frightening on this front
david ed this is one of those bizarre
stories that makes you take
extra steps when you are on your
computer and really pay attention
reuters is reporting exclusively
that hackers from north korea were
posing as recruiters
and contacted astrazeneca employees on
linkedin
and whatsapp almost everybody has access
to that across the
globe and was trying to send them
documents for jobs
and those documents had malicious code
inside them
that's how the hackers were able to try
to get
into those astrazeneca employees
computers to get some of that
information about the covet 19
vaccine seems like it could happen to
anybody now curiously this comes
at the same time as british drug maker
astrazeneca revealed
issues with its covet 19 vaccine trials
announcing the participants
received a lower dose making the
percentage less effective
great britain ed moving forward with the
vaccine but u.s officials are taking a
step back
doesn't mean we won't get the vaccine
it's being reevaluated as there is no
margin for error now north korea
is denying the hacking charges through
second and third channels
there's no direct contact with the
outside world in that country
reuters also reporting that some of the
accounts used to lure astrazeneca
employees were russian email addresses
a way to possibly mislead investigators
now reuters also reporting that the
attacking
the hacking attempts excuse me were not
successful that's the good news
reached out to the department of justice
and the fbi here in the united states
as typical they are not commenting on an
investigation edward
that is pretty shocking david thank you
very much
from the department of justice the